There is room on this dry stone, little ones, although Bongo has reserved half of it for a blueberry bowl.
What happens when you say yes very quickly, then discover that keeping your yes is much harder than saying it?
God cares whether our words can be trusted. That afternoon, three quick yeses were about to meet one very slow ten minutes.
One warm afternoon, Fern the young fawn had been watching a water-lily flower beside one broad green leaf since breakfast.
And three frogs who usually arrived with a question and left with four wrong answers wanted, for once, a serious job.
Shelly the young tortoise stood beside Fern's marker twig while Splish, Splash, and Splosh lined up on the bank.
We are ready for duty. Serious duty. My face is doing its least wiggly expression.
Mine is even less wiggly. I have moved all my wiggles into my left foot.
I have no wiggles. I have rules.
That is somehow more concerning.
I marked this leaf at breakfast. The flower beside it has been changing all day, and I need one final measure of how wide it stands open.
A final measure. That sounds very serious.
It sounds finaler than a normal measure.
State the rules.
For ten minutes, leave the marked leaf exactly as it is. Do not touch it, move it, blow it, splash it, or improve it.
Yes.
Yes yes.
Official yes. Stamped, filed, and wearing a small hat.
There is no hat.
The hat is official.
Bongo the bear cub arrived with blueberries, and Zippy the hummingbird arrived with three timers for one ten-minute job.
I brought guard snacks. I asked first, so the snacks are not helping without permission.
Timer one counts minutes, timer two checks timer one, and timer three asks whether time feels watched.
Time has declined to comment.
I will stay and write what the flower does. Shelly is fetching Professor Hoot's measuring reed.
If anything changes, call me. I will be close enough to hear.
This is the first flower watch I planned and announced myself. I would like to finish it the way I began it.
You announced it? Out loud? Then this job is serious twice.
Serious does not mean wearing a serious face. It means treating Fern's work as if it matters to you too.
Then we will care for it with our faces, our rules, and all our feet.
It will not become hard. It is a leaf.
Leaves are famously easy not to touch.
Begin Official Lily Watch.
Ten minutes remaining. Also ten minutes have always been remaining. This is our first announcement.
Shelly had taken exactly four slow steps when the first blueberry escaped Bongo's bowl.
That berry has left the bowl without permission.
The blueberry rolled toward the marked leaf, slow enough to be insulting and fast enough to require a decision.
I can blow it away. Breath has no hands.
Shelly said not to blow the leaf.
I would blow the berry. The leaf would merely experience nearby weather.
I can blow from the other side, so the weather cancels itself.
Denied. Two weathers make climate.
Two breaths do not make climate.
Then they make a tiny weather argument.
I can pick up my own berry if somebody tells me where to put my paws.
Left paw on the flat stone. Right paw behind the bowl. Reach from the bank, not over the water.
Left, right, bank. I got this carefully.
Bongo reached. The berry rolled one berry-width farther. Bongo froze so completely that Zippy checked whether bears could pause.
Confirmed. Bear paused. Nine minutes, twenty-seven seconds remain.
The berry is nearly touching our not-touching leaf.
Official ruling: berries are not frogs. The promise contains no berry clause.
The promise was to leave the leaf exactly as it is.
Exactly as it is, except possibly beside one blueberry.
No. My snack should not become Fern's experiment. I am moving the whole bowl away.
On his second reach, Bongo caught the berry, but his elbow nudged the bowl and two more berries started rolling.
I have created a berry meeting.
Hold the bowl against the flat stone first. Then gather the two rolling berries.
On his third attempt, Bongo steadied the bowl, caught both berries, and carried every snack beyond rolling distance.
Guard snacks are now distant snacks. I will miss them with great care.
Eight minutes, fifty-two seconds. No leaf contact. One berry incident. One excellent snack move.
Official Lily Watch remains flawless.
Could we inspect the underside without touching the top?
No.
Could we inspect it from below while facing the top?
Still no.
Excellent guarding. We have found two forbidden directions.
What about sideways?
The answer has stopped travelling.
For nearly a whole minute, they watched using only their eyes. It was the longest minute ever recorded by three frogs.
Seven minutes, forty-one seconds remain. Your minute was truly nineteen seconds.
That explains why it felt slightly short for forever.
You can count the leaf veins from here. Looking is allowed, counting is quiet, and neither one needs a tower.
I count eleven.
I count twenty-two because I counted each one louder.
I count one leaf. I have won counting.
There are seventeen large veins on the side we can see. You stayed on the bank and learned something true.
That worked, which means we should immediately improve it with equipment.
I have a watching reed. A reed can look more closely than an eye.
A reed cannot look.
Then it has been holding the wrong end toward things for years.
Splish balanced the watching reed above the leaf. Splash held Splish steady. Splosh called it a tower and opened a meeting about touching.
The reed is not a frog. Therefore the frog has not touched the leaf.
Does the leaf know who is holding the reed?
Leaves know less than reeds. This experiment is becoming worrying.
Closer. Just a little closer. Not touching is easier when you can see exactly what you are not touching.
The reed dipped. The leaf lifted. The marker twig moved one small twig-width across the water.
That was not a touch. That was a very short meeting.
My marker moved.
Recording: reed touched leaf, leaf lifted, marker moved at six minutes and fifty-one seconds remaining.
Record instead: leaf held an unasked meeting with reed.
I only have a truth column. The other columns hold seconds, smaller seconds, and tiny fractions.
I heard the marker move. Do you need me to bring Shelly back? I can go carefully and also quickly, in that order.
Not yet. Official Lily Watch repairs its own official lilies.
The lily is not official. But I will stay close enough to hear a different answer.
I need Shelly. I am saying that now, even if the brothers are not ready to say it with me.
We can move the marker back exactly. Then it will be as if the moving never moved.
But it did move.
Only in the first version of what happened.
There is only one version of what happened.
Then it is fortunate we are still editing it.
The plain truth was waiting at the edge of the afternoon. The brothers were not ready to say it.
New plan. We move the water, not the marker. Water has no promise.
We make one tiny ripple from very far away.
Approved, provided the ripple signs the visitor book.
Please stop. The measure is already changed. More moving will not make it unchanged.
We are Official Lily Watch. We cannot finish with a moved marker.
You can finish by telling Shelly what happened.
Then we become Former Official Lily Watch.
And everybody will remember why serious jobs usually go to creatures with fewer songs about mud.
We asked for one job that was not a joke.
I did not think your yes was a joke. I thought you would call Shelly when I asked.
Five minutes, twelve seconds remain. I can call Shelly now, or I can keep counting while this gets harder.
Keep counting.
Make the ripple.
Three frogs jumped at the far bank. Their ripple moved the leaf and tipped the reed tower into the shallows.
The ripple moved it more.
And the tower fell.
Fern... we did that.
My flower measure is gone for today.
Nobody spoke for a breath. The flower kept closing, and no rule could make the afternoon begin again.
I moved the leaf with the reed.
I suggested the ripple after Fern asked us to stop.
I cared more about keeping the title than keeping the promise.
Thank you for saying the true parts. What happens next must be true too.
Four minutes, thirty-eight seconds remain. Shelly is still away. This is the last moment to tell her before she discovers it.
Splash, you call loudest.
Shelly! Please come back now! Not in four minutes. We need the true version while it is still hard to say!
I will find her. Fern, tell me first: do you need me to stay or go?
Go, please. Bring Shelly. I will keep the marker where it drifted.
Bongo took three careful steps and one very fast fourth. Shelly met him halfway, carrying Hoot's measuring reed.
You called before the ten minutes ended.
Did you call because I saw the moved marker, or because you chose to tell me before I could see it?
You had not seen it. That was the point. We wanted one true thing to happen before you arrived.
I touched the leaf with a reed after you said not to touch or move it.
I made us send a ripple after Fern said the measure was already changed.
I tried to change Zippy's record because I wanted the Official Lily Watch title to stay ours.
My record says berry, reed, moved marker, stop request, ripple, fallen tower, confession. In that order.
Fern, what did their choices cost your work?
I cannot use today's final measure. I will need to mark another leaf tomorrow and watch again.
Then Official Lily Watch is over. We give the title back.
We can take down every reed and put the marker beside Fern's notebook.
And tomorrow we can carry things, not guard the leaf. Our feet are less likely to get that job wrong.
Start with the reeds. Bongo can restore the marker where Fern directs. Zippy keeps the record unchanged.
They worked before anyone explained the afternoon. Reeds came down. The twig returned. Fern chose tomorrow's place.
This reed touched the leaf. I am putting it with the record, not back where somebody could mistake it for innocent.
These were the ripple reeds. I am carrying them to the bank one at a time because a pile would become another idea.
And this leaf badge says Official Lily Watch. I am placing it beside Fern's notebook. It does not belong on me today.
I will keep it with today's record, not throw it away. Tomorrow will show what you do next.
Marker left one leaf-width, Fern? I am asking because my paws have opinions.
One leaf-width left. Thank you for asking.
Two minutes, nine seconds remain. The first test is over. The honest record is complete.
I thought asking for help would make our yes smaller.
Not asking made the problem enormous. It had a tower.
Tomorrow our yes will include four words: we will tell you.
The ten minutes ended without a bell, a tick, or another invention. Zippy simply lowered her smallest timer.
Zero minutes remain. Time reports that it felt heavily watched.
Splosh, what did your yes need when keeping it became difficult?
Truth sooner. Help sooner. Fewer rules.
A yes does not become honest because you explain around it very cleverly.
And saying this is hard is not the same as saying no. It might be how you keep your yes from becoming pretend.
Tomorrow, I can trust that sentence.
My careful yes today was moving the berries. If I had dropped them again, I would have asked Fern where to step again.
My yes was keeping the record unchanged, even when somebody asked for a wrong column.
And my yes was returning when you called. Being trusted does not mean never needing another person.
Mm. They had found the meaning before I reached for the Bible. That is usually the best way for a story to arrive at a verse.
In the Bible, Matthew chapter five, verse thirty-seven records Jesus saying it plainly:
But let your communication be, Yea, yea; Nay, nay: for whatsoever is more than these cometh of evil.
Communication here means what we say. Jesus was teaching that our yes should be true and our no should be true without piling extra promises around them.
The last phrase says extra promises and slippery explanations come from evil because they make room for hiding the truth. A plain answer needs no tower around it.
That verse has excellent rules.
It has two rules.
That leaves lots of room for snacks.
Distant snacks are ready again. I kept my yes to moving them, and now I am giving a careful yes to sharing.
Tomorrow's flower watch starts after breakfast. You may carry the notebook and tell me if your feet begin making plans.
Our feet will submit all plans in writing.
Professor Hoot the owl arrived with his measuring reed and the expression of someone whose fact had been delayed.
Many water-lily flowers follow a daily opening-and-closing rhythm. Some open in morning light and begin closing later in the day.
So the flower keeps opening the same shop every morning?
For several flowering days, yes. Light and a plant signal called auxin help time the petals.
Ox in?
Auxin. A plant signal. No ox.
That is good. An ox would need a very wide leaf.
Closing is part of a rhythm the flower can repeat.
Then tomorrow is the next flower watch. The flower will do its part again.
Precisely. I had intended to say that with more syllables, but the fawn has supplied an efficient summary.
When your yes becomes hard, tell the truth early. If a promise feels unsafe, confusing, or too big, ask a trusted grown-up for help.
Also keep blueberries beyond rolling distance.
The brothers are filing tomorrow's foot plans now. There are seventeen pages. We may need a smaller yes.
See you next time, somewhere in Shiloh Creek.